it's so close Witcher threes final DLC
is going out with a bang with over 30
hours of content that's a whole new game
if you're like me you might be a tad
rusty getting back into the Witcher and
with a whole new area littered with new
monsters armor and mutagens you're
probably going to want to take a stern
look at your last character save before
you venture into Tucson so here's your
guide on how to better prepare yourself
for blood and wine first off level up
the very first mission for blood and
wine recommends you be a level 34 so
give or take you probably want to be
around level 30 when you step foot into
Tucson luckily if you're itching to dive
into blood wine you'll be able to jump
into a level 35 pre-made character just
make sure you spend the time to reapply
those ability points and if you decide
to take the pre-made character route
there's a plus side and reshuffling your
ability points and that you get to
better suit your character for Tucson
you'll be facing a couple new cursive
ones and necrophagous in which case
boosting your igni sign is a plus not
that you haven't already but the real
kicker that blood wine is packing
vampires
lots of vampires and what do vampires
hate that's right Jordan so beef that
sign up and while we're on vampires
you'll run into some that like cloaking
in which case stock up on moondust bonds
even upgrading them to superior if you
really want to catch those sneaky
bloodsuckers oh and don't forget to
lather that sword with vampire oil
before you go nuts on customizing those
skills consider holding back and
conserving some of those ability points
because we're moving on to mutagens
blood and wines packing a whole new
mutagen skill tree that's definitely
worth considering within this tree lies
12 new mutation abilities such as
piercing cold and upgrade to the art
sign that allows you to freeze enemies
where they stand these game changers do
require a lot of greater mutagens and
lots of unused ability points once you
got Geralt score skills and abilities
out of the way let's move on to Phase
two
wardrobe essentially there are two paths
you can take when considering your armor
one if you've done it already
you can take your previous
master crafted armor like Griffon or
feline and take it one step further
blood and wine brings Grand Master
Armour oh yeah a whole new upgrade to
your fit but maybe you're sick of your
current fitting and you want to start
from scratch no problem because you get
the new armor Manticore to work towards
looks good and if that wasn't enough the
real icing on the cake is that blood and
wine brings unique perks to fully
completed armor sets for instance if you
complete the manticore set you get a
perk that brings critical hit chance to
the bombs you throw that had me stoked
there you have it a nice Witcher to-do
list before blood wine rolls out on may
31st
be sure to stay tuned to games for more
with your content down the road and if
you have any pointers yourself feel free
to hit me up on Twitter thanks for
watching
you